you have so many moments and so many
good movies like the scene in Old School
yes
that's awesome
you're crazy
I like you
that was hard
um to not I think that what helped me to
not up takes was
I didn't want to disappoint will but the
good thing was that my character is
entertained by what remember I think
because I think once he shoots himself
in the neck with the dart I'm like
that's awesome and so I was able
to at least if I if I had to play it
straight it would have been impossible
because he was adding stuff he was
adding like I like you
but you crazy when I hit the line that
he added that it kind of gets lost as he
walks away and he's like so tired yeah
yeah I'm so tired I'm super tired